you're watching the free pilot training
channel where today we're going to be
discussing vfr sectionals and how we can
use those to pick safe altitudes to fly
at
as a pilot some of the most dangerous
situations that we get into
are because of obstructions to flight
and some of the most common obstructions
these days are man-made obstacles like
this one
to help us avoid these when these
obstacles are taller than 200 feet
they're charted on our vfr sectional
take a look at this obstacle here
this is the basic obstacle symbol when
we see this symbol we know there's an
obstacle here that's at least 200 feet
tall but less than a thousand
let's zoom in a little bit closer so we
can see exactly how tall this thing is
the upper bold number tells us the
elevation of the top of the tower in
mean sea level
the top of this particular tower is at 1
343 feet
msl then this lower number tells us the
obstacle's height in feet above the
ground
so this thing's height is 275 feet agl
here's a cool little bonus tip for you
if you take the elevation to the top of
the tower and you subtract the height
from that
this will give you your ground elevation
at that specific spot this can come in
really handy when you're planning a
flight in an area where you're not
familiar with
now check out this monster obstacle this
is a symbol you'll see when the tower is
taller than a thousand feet agl
notice they tell you exactly where the
top of the tower is the same way they do
the smaller ones
now let me ask you a question how many
obstacles are depicted right here
now while this picture clearly shows two
obstacles it's impossible for us to know
exactly how many are really there and
that's because this is a group
obstacle symbol when they build these
charts they make every effort to chart
every obstacle individually but if there
are too many in one location and the
chart becomes cluttered they'll put the
symbol here
instead and these numbers beside it
indicate the tallest obstacle in that
group
another thing you might see when the
chart starts getting too cluttered is
that they'll leave out the height and
only put the elevation of the obstacle
if they ask you what the height of this
tower is on the test you'll have to take
this number
and subtract the ground elevation from
the nearest airfield
now check this out as i'm sure you're
already aware this is a windmill farm
but notice the individual altitudes of
these windmills aren't shown here
instead they give you the elevation of
the tallest windmill in mean sea level
right here just be careful with this
though because if you ever see the
letters
you see beside this number that means
this elevation is unverified
and speaking of that you could
potentially see these letters beside any
tower
this just means that it's either under
construction or the elevation at the top
is unverified
for any one of these symbols you could
see these little lightning bolts on top
of them
and that just tells us that these
obstacles have high intensity lights on
top of them
and that makes them just a little bit
easier to spot now comes the important
question
just how close can i get to these towers
and obstructions to flight
to figure that out we need to pull out
the federal aviation regulations
specifically we're going to be looking
in part 91 119
first everywhere on the map if you lose
an engine you must be able to make an
emergency landing without undue hazard
to something or someone on the ground
but then we have congested areas and
these are simply cities
towns settlements or any open assembly
of people
in these areas you need to keep your
airplane a thousand feet above the
highest obstacle
within a two thousand foot radius of the
aircraft
now on the test they're going to tell
you whether you're in a congested or
uncongested area
but in real life if i'm anywhere near
these yellow areas i'm going to call
that area congested
so let's say i'm within two thousand
feet of this obstacle right here
at what altitude do i need to fly well
the elevation of the top of this tower
is at 2758 feet
so all i have to do is add a thousand
feet to that that means if i fly at 3758
feet
msl i'm meeting this requirement that
being said
in other than congested areas i can fly
my airplane as low as 500 feet above the
surface
just be kind of careful if you do this
because these taller towers can pop up
out of nowhere here's something crazy
though over water and sparsely populated
areas you can fly your airplane as low
as you want
you just can't get any closer than 500
feet to any person
vessel vehicle or structure now time for
a pop quiz
do you know what these blue numbers are
in the middle of these 30-minute
segments of latitude and longitude
these are called maximum elevation
figures and they're excellent tools for
picking safe altitudes to fly at
let me explain how these work there are
two ways that these are calculated
the first way is if a man-made obstacle
is the highest thing in that quadrant
it looks like it's a tower in this group
obstacle symbol that's 1904 feet msl
then most of the time they add 100 feet
to account for vertical
air then we simply add these numbers up
and round to the next hundred feet
so in this case we've got 2100 feet and
that's where they get this number from
so theoretically if you fly over this
number within a 30 mile radius
you should be safe from any towers or
other obstructions
the other way they calculate this is
when natural terrain is the highest
thing in that quadrant
they'll start by taking the elevation of
that terrain in this example it's a
mountain peak that's 13
684 feet then once again we add 100 feet
for vertical air
now sometimes they do use half the
contour level instead of the 100 feet
but you don't really need to know that
for this training next they add 200 feet
and that's because only obstacles over
200 feet are required to be charted on
vfr
sectionals because of that there could
be a 199 foot tower on the peak of this
mountain
and they wouldn't be required to chart
it then we simply add these numbers up
then round to the next hundred feet
and this gives us our maximum elevation
figure
thanks for studying with me today please
consider subscribing if you haven't
already and be sure to check out this
video
or maybe this playlist see ya